talk to me about marriage and kids
because i mean
it seems like your
um
best material or the stuff that people
seem to recognize you for the most is
sort of like built around that
uh family dynamic that like the
traditional conservative like the
tradcon sort of
values um
talk about the expectations that you had
as a man getting into marriage versus
the reality of what you experienced once
you were in it and then the kids started
to arrive
yeah i mean it's it's um it's a hard
thing you know it's uh it was a
challenge because i really didn't have
um
a model you know i i don't i didn't know
what a good marriage looked like i
didn't know what a good relationship
looked like i i i kind of always felt
especially now as i have a father
i'm a father of four
um i've always felt like i've been a
father at heart
in a way like maybe old for for my years
and i feel like even just now i'm coming
into it for myself but yeah i never had
an example of what it was supposed to
look like and how a husband honors his
wife and raises his children man i just
didn't see that so i struggled as
evidenced by except the separation i had
with my wife um
man i struggled and it was a challenge
and it was a chore and i'm like i don't
know what to do and i'm trying to leave
my family and i'm trying to grow this
business and i don't know how to do this
and i was losing my cool and calm and
patience i call it losing your frame
like i had no fr not even i didn't even
lose my frame i had no frame whatsoever
uh and so i had to build that and when i
started to build that for myself is
where the marriage changed because i
mean let's be real that's that's what a
woman generally i think
not always not exclusively but generally
a woman's looking for a man with a frame
with some balls somebody who's gonna
lead them in a masculine way and i
didn't have it and that's why my wife
responded the way she did
and the way that she responds now to the
way i lead so
so when you use the word frame i think i
understand it the same way that you use
it um you know in every relationship
there's there's a frame of the guy and
there's a frame of the woman and
generally speaking whoever enters the
other person's frame becomes the leader
in that relationship i think for the
most part today it seems like most guys
enter the women's frame
and um
like i see uh content out there now
around female-led relationships like
there's actually like social media sites
and there's blogs that are built around
this now where it's like they encourage
women to
make web like men less so they can
become more and then the man enters
their frame and sort of like you know
serves them you know the man puts her up
on the pedestal did you ever do that
like that's not how your marriage runs
right now like it sounds like she's in
your
frame yeah i would say that um
and i i don't know if i ever
went into her frame the way that you're
exp explaining it necessarily but what
you're saying
makes sense i haven't heard it described
that way but as they're saying that i'm
thinking to myself yeah that makes sense
because as a young man who doesn't have
a dad in his life
whose frame are you in well you're in
your mother's frame
she leads everything she makes all the
decisions she makes the financial
decisions she tells you when to eat what
to eat like everything right and so if
you've never had that masculine presence
where you have a father who's not
telling you like i don't want my my boys
i have three boys and a girl i don't
want my boys to
perpetually live under my thumb like i
want them to go out like my son the
other day he got mad about something and
i saw it in his eyes and he challenged
me
like not physically but he challenged me
in a way i hadn't seen before he's
almost 14 now and i'm like this is good
this this is what i want
like like now look
you're going to challenge me in my house
like i'm going to win that battle all
day long but this is a healthy behavior
i want to see this in you
but a but a but a boy who doesn't have
that is always going to be under the
wing of his mother and so when he leaves
the nest
and he's out on his own he's like oh
he's lost he's confused he's scared and
so he finds a woman who has the same
frame as his mother and then he becomes
her uh uh her um
her child you know and so i i think what
you're saying is
it's pretty accurate although i've never
heard it explained that way it makes
sense yeah um
dude as desi as a question for you says
what's the best way to beat out decades
of betatization
you gotta you gotta spend time with
other men
like you have to do masculine things and
you have to be around those kind of men
that you want to be around because when
i spend time with other men they're not
beta type men they're strong courageous
bold assertive convicted men and and i
learn from them what that looks like and
we do masculine activities
and and so we we spend time in the
wilderness together we push each other
we do jiu jitsu together we try to beat
each other up in a controlled
environment of course you know so
that changes you
that's the great thing about it is that
you can learn if you i have a lot of
guys who'll reach out and they'll say
hey i didn't have a dad in my life and i
don't know how to be a man so like what
do i do now well like it's not too late
you just need what you needed 20 years
ago you just do it now yeah you know my
behind be behind the eight ball a little
bit but it's okay so one of the first
things the alternative guys to do is to
join the dojo and start fighting
for sure 100 right 100 i'll let me give
you an example um
i don't i'm not gonna like say names or
anything here and i'll try to be pretty
general here but like i've i've trained
jiu-jitsu and when another man puts his
hands on you and grabs you you can tell
a lot about that individual immediately
right
um and and i've been training with a
couple of guys who have just got it
started and they grab you and it's
almost like feminine in a way
when they put their hands on you and
it's like
it's like hey man and i told i told
somebody the other day i'm like like
like grab me like you mean it like
violently grab me and he had a hard time
doing that and and i don't i don't know
his situation
i'm jumping to conclusions here but i i
think generally
you can see a lot about the way that a
man asserts himself especially in that
physically
heavy environment yeah they'll come away
with a nice lesson when you fold them
into a pretzel in their clothing and
send them home right
they might or they might run away and
cower and never come back like that's up
to them you know and i like to see the
guy
just like i was who's like oh [ __ ] i
never want that to happen to me again
that when i started training jiu jitsu
you know i got beat up i got banged up
and i didn't i didn't run away i was
like i gotta figure that out because
there's no man who should ever be able
to do that to me again hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you